[MUSIC PLAYING]
JAMES GIANGOLA: Hi,
I'm James Giangola
from Google's
Conversation Design Team,
and I'm here to show
you how to apply
the built-in hacks of
everyday conversation
to create cutting edge,
effortless, frictionless,
voice user interface
designs, or VUIs.
Now, a hack is a good
thing, in the sense
of a creative, quick thinking,
agile, clever shortcut.
But I looked in the
dictionary, and the dictionary
says that hacks are
inelegant solutions.
So just so you know,
because this is how I roll.
I'm going to be
offering you a feast
of hack-like but
elegant solutions,
all courtesy of mother nature.
That said, the title of
this talk could have been,
[AUDIO PLAYBACK]
- Are you sitting down?
[END PLAYBACK]
JAMES GIANGOLA: Great.
You're all sitting down,
but think about it.
In a conversation,
are you sitting down
is a mental hack, isn't it?
It's a shortcut.
If you're on the phone and your
friend or whoever asks you,
are you sitting
down, there not just
asking you how your body is
physically positioned in space.
They're actually
telling you something.
They're telling you, brace
yourself for some heavy news.
You see, we have
this amazing ability,
and we take it for
granted all the time.
We have this amazing
ability to look
beyond superficial
meanings and instead, we
seek out deeper,
hidden ones based
on the expectations of
how the world and how
our culture works.
This ability is a
reflex of what's
called the
cooperative principle.
So I'm going to talk
about our instinct
to behave cooperatively
in a conversation,
not just to behave
cooperatively ourselves,
but also to expect the same
from others, including software,
including virtual assistants,
which is why you're here today.
First, we'll explore the
co-operative principle
human to human.
Then we'll turn to different
areas of conversation design,
where there are opportunities
to apply the principle in order
to create a superior
user experience.
I'm going to show you how
to make your actions more
intuitive, more comfortable,
more relevant, and more
likeable for your users.
And I'll show you how
mastery of this principle
will save you and
your designs from some
of the amateur
pitfalls that make
VUIs so frustrating to use.
I'm going to show you a lot
of before and after examples,
redesigns, so that you
get the hang of it.
So let's begin.
What do you guys think of
the following exchanges,
and what do you infer about
the personality of the speakers
Leslie and Max, in particular.
How likeable are these people?
Let's listen.
[AUDIO PLAYBACK]
- Do you know who's
coming to the party?
- Yes.
Can you play a song for me?
- No.
[END PLAYBACK]
JAMES GIANGOLA: So, what's
strange about these exchanges?
Grammatically, these
are yes/no questions.
They're looking
for yes/no answers,
but there's something
uncomfortable
about the literal yes/no
responses themselves.
What is it?
Max and Leslie don't
sound cooperative.
Why doesn't Max just go
ahead and tell Leslie who
all was attending the party?
What is the reason--
I want to know the reason--
why Leslie can't
indulge max with a tune?
Based on these brief
exchanges, would you
want these people to
represent your brand?
Would you endorse them
at all for employment?
Probably not.
These examples show
that conversation
is more than just the literal
exchange of information.
According to the
cooperative principle,
we humans naturally
assume and expect
there to be an
undercurrent of cooperation
between participants
or interlocutors
of a conversation.
This applies to
the truth of what
we say, the amount of
information that we provide,
the relevance of
what we contribute,
and the way, in
good faith, we try
to communicate clearly, without
obscurity, without ambiguity.
In the 1970s, the conversation
theorist Paul Grice,
stated each one of these
in the form of a rule,
known as Grice's Maxims.
But for the sake of
simplicity, let's just
call it the
cooperative principle.
It's a nice umbrella
term for our purposes.
So today, I'd like to focus
on the Maxims of Quantity
and Manner.
These are the two
that will give you
the biggest bang for the buck
in the limited time we've got.
The Maxim of Quantity gives
us a principled understanding
of why Max and Leslie's
yes and no responses were
uncooperative.
You see, according to
this rule of conversation,
a speaker provides
as much information
as is necessary to
advance the perceived
purpose of the conversation,
but not too much.
And I'm going to show you lots
of examples of that as well.
Since Max and Leslie's
answers didn't
provide enough information
to fulfill a purpose
or to meaningfully
move the topic forward,
they violated the
Maxim of Quantity.
And that's what's wrong
with those conversations,
despite good grammar.
You can find the
Maxim of Quantity
in the supermarket in
the condiment section.
Doesn't the word tomato seem
uninformative or redundant
on the label tomato ketchup.
After all, isn't all
ketchup made from tomatoes?
In fact, the phrase
tomato ketchup
was once very informative.
Since the tomato was an
innovative substitution
for mollusks, in other
words oysters, mussels, etc.
likewise, when people say
lady doctor or male nurse
or white trash,
they're informatively
revealing their prejudice
that doctors are--
irony quotes--
supposed to be male.
Nurses are supposed
to be female,
and trash is not supposed
to be white, an insidious
racial slur.
Not funny.
This is an insidious racial
slur that most people don't even
realize.
So what's going on here?
People obey the
Maxim of Quantity,
and they tell you what
they think you need
to know for better or worse.
And so often, this happens
automatically, unconsciously.
This next example's really key.
Pay attention.
[AUDIO PLAYBACK]
- I really need a drink.
- Have you been to the Eagle?
[END PLAYBACK]
The answer is a
question, but Alex
must be cooperating with Sammy.
This can't be a
non sequitur right?
Assuming the
co-operative principle,
we can actually
make five inferences
from the answer,
which is a question,
have you been to the Eagle?
One, the Eagle serves drinks.
Two, the drinks are
probably alcoholic.
Let's hope so.
Three, the Eagle's
open for business.
It's operational.
Four, the Eagle is nearby.
It's in driving distance.
It's not in Fresno
or Nova Scotia.
And the Eagle is a place that
Sammy would probably like.
Think of how important the
cooperative principle must've
been in terms of the evolution
of the human species.
We wouldn't get
much accomplished
if we had to spell
everything out,
unpacking each
and every thought,
as if we had to
explain how things
work to aliens unfamiliar
with our terrestrial ways.
What Alex just did there
on that last slide,
is an example of
conversational implicature.
That is, the speaker
has just said
something that leads the
listener to make an inference.
In this case, five of them.
Speakers make implicatures,
and listeners make inferences
all the time.
And these shortcuts
are the fallout
of the cooperative
principle acting
on a library of shared
world knowledge, knowledge
that we share with
our interlocutor.
In the next example, we can make
an inference that you probably
take for granted.
So the sentence is, last night,
I saw Chris at a restaurant
with a woman.
Obviously, the woman was
not her friend Chris's wife,
even though biologically,
his wife is a woman.
How do we know
it's not his wife?
Well, if she were
his or her wife,
the speaker would have said so
in the interest of providing
a satisfactory
amount of information
to move the conversation
forward, the Maxim of Quantity.
The next example.
[AUDIO PLAYBACK]
PAT: How much
longer will you be?
JAMIE: Fix yourself a snack.
[END PLAYBACK]
JAMES GIANGOLA: Notice how
the superficial invitation
to go make a sandwich actually
indicates an amount of time
that the listener is
probably not happy with.
What if the listener has
said, I'm putting my shoes on?
Right, the listener would
have been a lot happier.
The next example's
already familiar,
but let's add some more context.
[AUDIO PLAYBACK]
- Hey, what did that
letter from the IRS say?
- Are you sitting down?
[END PLAYBACK]
JAMES GIANGOLA: And
here's a speaker who
appears to be uncooperative, but
she's actually being very nice.
[AUDIO PLAYBACK]
- Hey, how did the
interview go with that guy
from Dunder Mifflin?
- Well, he was on time, and he
was wearing a beautiful tie.
[END PLAYBACK]
JAMES GIANGOLA: We could be
confident that the speaker
cannot recommend this
candidate for employment.
The primary piece of
shared world knowledge
that makes this
implicature possible
is our familiarity
with the saying,
if you haven't got
something nice to say
about someone, right?
Let's compare two answers
to the same question.
[AUDIO PLAYBACK]
MAX: How much did you
pay for that shirt?
CHRIS: Don't you love it?
I got it at Vinnie's Vintage.
[END PLAYBACK]
JAMES GIANGOLA: Versus.
[AUDIO PLAYBACK]
MAX: How much did you
pay for that shirt?
CHRIS: Don't you love it?
Shirt has five letters, and
five is my favorite number.
[END PLAYBACK]
JAMES GIANGOLA: I'm
glad you laughed.
Why is one OK and not the other?
Neither one answered
the question.
Why is one good
and the other bad?
It's because the first one
has a basis in shared world
knowledge, which is, it's
not cool to ask people
how much their stuff costs.
The implicature here
is I won't tell you
how much my stuff
costs, but here's
where you can go and
find out yourself.
Now, let's see how we can
apply the cooperative principle
and conversation
implicature to VUI design.
Here's an example of a
conversation implicature
from the Google Home
Timer Application.
A timer is going off, and
the user says thank you.
What should happen next?
The system should infer that
this an expression of gratitude
is only superficial.
Drawing on her store of
shared world knowledge,
the assistant should
understand the hack-like nature
of thank you in this context.
By implicature, the user
is really saying, OK,
you can turn it off.
That will be all.
Besides drawing inferences,
a good assistant
should also observe
the Maxim of Quantity.
[AUDIO PLAYBACK]
- Show me pictures of the
state flower of California.
- The state flower of
California, here you go.
By the way, it's called
the California Poppy.
[END PLAYBACK]
JAMES GIANGOLA:
Here the assistant
infers that the user does not
know the name of the flower,
otherwise, they
would have used it.
So she provides that
extra info, the quantity,
to fill in the likely gap
in the user's knowledge.
In this next example,
the user needs a ride,
so they ask their assistant
to speak to Droover.
Droover answers, and
here's what happens next.
[AUDIO PLAYBACK]
- Hello.
Droover here.
Unfortunately, I
don't see any drivers
within 20 minutes of you, but
you can try again another time.
[END PLAYBACK]
JAMES GIANGOLA: And the
interaction just comes
to a halt. Cooperative?
Is that cooperative?
Here's one possible redesign
of that application that
would advance the user's
intent cooperatively and
informatively.
[AUDIO PLAYBACK]
- Hello.
Droover here.
The nearest car is
20 minutes away.
Does that work for you?
- No.
- I can check again in
two or three minutes.
Are you still interested?
- All right.
[END PLAYBACK]
JAMES GIANGOLA: Seems
more cooperative,
more likable doesn't it?
I think so.
Now, this next example is a
VUI adaption of a real GUI.
The interaction isn't
conversational either.
Again, it just dead ends, comes
to an abrupt halt at the end.
The context here is a power
user knows that the delivery
charge is usually $4.99.
[AUDIO PLAYBACK]
- Yes, ready to pay.
- For this hour,
the delivery charge
has temporarily changed to
$7.99 due to the high volume
of orders received at
Tasty Noodle House.
Would you still like the
proceed to check out?
- No.
[END PLAYBACK]
JAMES GIANGOLA: And the
interaction just stops.
We can improve on this.
How can we make this app's
persona more appealing,
more socially intelligent?
Well, here's my
idea for a redesign.
[AUDIO PLAYBACK]
- Yes, ready to pay.
- Just so you know, between
8:00 and 9:00 tonight,
the delivery charge for this
particular restaurant is $7.99.
Do you want to go ahead
and place your order?
- No.
- In that case, there
are some other options
in that area that
are pretty similar.
Are you interested?
- Sure.
Why not.
- OK, here are two other
noodle places nearby.
Noodle and Doodle in
Malverne, and there's
Rasta Pasta in Valley Stream.
[END PLAYBACK]
JAMES GIANGOLA: So
we've seen examples
of informative assistance.
Now, let's turn to our users
who can't resist the instinct
to cooperate, to meaningfully
advance the conversation as
if they were interacting
with another human.
[AUDIO PLAYBACK]
- And how many people are going?
- It's my wife and myself.
[END PLAYBACK]
JAMES GIANGOLA: Unfortunately,
cooperative informative
contributions like my wife
and myself will likely
be rejected by the
recognizer, which is often
built to expect superficial,
literal responses
like the number two.
So that so-called error
that you just heard
is actually an example
of verbal cooperation.
If the recognition grammar can't
handle cooperative responses,
then use the rapid re-prompt
strategy in the first level,
no match prompt.
For instance, sorry,
how many was that?
Compare a nice conversational
prompt like sorry,
how many was that?
With typical VUI speak, which
should be something like, I'm
sorry, I didn't catch that.
Please speak to the number
of people in your party.
You can say, for example, two.
Everyone seems to prefer the
conversational version, which
happens to debunk the
myth that conversational
means long winded and verbose.
In this next example, the
VUI offers the possibility
of paying right now with
either Visa or MasterCard,
but notice the way the
user's prompted to respond.
[AUDIO PLAYBACK]
- Great.
You can make a payment right
now with Visa or MasterCard.
So would you like to pay now?
[END PLAYBACK]
JAMES GIANGOLA: The VUI seems
to be offering an either
or choice, but then serves
the user a yes/no question.
So the persona's
intent feels ambiguous.
The recognition
grammar was designed
to accept only yes,
no, and synonyms.
So cooperative users who
said things like, yes, visa
were served an error prompt.
You see, if you know about
the cooperative principle,
you don't need to find out
about the stuff after the fact.
You can spare yourselves time
consuming and expensive user
research or the damage
control of having
to make major tuning changes
to your recognition grammar
after the fact.
On the next slide,
we have no input
prompt that exemplifies a
long time industry standard.
Let's listen.
[AUDIO PLAYBACK]
- I'm sorry.
I didn't hear anything.
What is your account number?
[END PLAYBACK]
JAMES GIANGOLA: A no input
prompt when the user hasn't
said anything at all.
So put on the defensive,
a cooperative user
would be justified
in explaining,
you didn't hear anything,
because I didn't say anything.
It's likely that a user
hasn't spoken, because they
haven't heard the question.
Maybe they were distracted.
They weren't paying attention.
Here are a couple of
more socially appropriate
re-prompts.
[AUDIO PLAYBACK]
- To get started, tell
me your account number.
[END PLAYBACK]
JAMES GIANGOLA: Yes.
Just paraphrase it and ask as
if they never heard the question
to begin with.
Here's another way
you could do it.
[AUDIO PLAYBACK]
- Your account number
is 10 digits long,
and you can find
it on your bill.
It's in the upper right hand
corner, just under the date.
[END PLAYBACK]
JAMES GIANGOLA: In VUI design,
this re-prompting strategy
is called escalating detail,
but the more general design term
in other areas of
design outside of VUI
is progressive disclosure.
Think about it.
If I ask you a question,
and you don't answer.
And then I come back
with you and say
I didn't hear anything,
that is so freaking rude.
That's bad parenting.
You can't do that.
Stop it.
But we've been doing that
for 20 years or more.
Yes, we have to stop.
Dis-confirmations are
when a user answers
no to a confirmation prompt.
Dis-confirmations are a
particularly gnarly problem
in VUI design, and we can
understand the challenge
in terms of the cooperative
principle in particular,
the Maxim of Quantity.
So here's an example of
a confirmation prompt.
Let's listen.
[AUDIO PLAYBACK]
- Let me confirm that.
That's from Boston to New
York on July 15th, at 6:00 PM.
Did I get that right?
[END PLAYBACK]
JAMES GIANGOLA: Now, when
the information is correct,
users say yes or some synonym.
Everybody's happy.
But when it's wrong, that's
the dis-confirmation.
Users elaborate.
And those cooperative details
generally elude the recognizer
as we can see on the right.
Obviously, it's not practical to
put each and every one of these
in your recognition grammar.
You're going to dilute
the recognition accuracy.
As Tolstoy said in his
novel Anna Karenina,
happy families are all alike.
Every unhappy family is unhappy,
each in its own way, right?
That's what's going on here.
So here are some
possible re-prompts.
[AUDIO PLAYBACK]
- Sorry, was that right?
Sorry, did I get that right?
[END PLAYBACK]
JAMES GIANGOLA:
Usability studies
have shown, time and time
again, that people just
need a brief second chance to
recover from a misrecognition
error.
This conversation approach
stands in sharp contrast
to industry cliches
like this one.
[AUDIO PLAYBACK]
- If this is correct, say yes.
Otherwise, say no.
[END PLAYBACK]
JAMES GIANGOLA: When
I hear this prompt,
I don't imagine a friendly face.
I see a flowchart.
I see arrows springing from
boxes, going from box to box.
This style is inconsistent
with the assistant metaphor,
and so it undermines
the integrity
of the design of the
assistant user experience.
Unfortunately, VUI users have
had so many bad experiences
with speech
recognition technology
and with amateur VUI
designs, that they've
been trained over the years
to say as little as possible.
They'll also take prompts
at their literal superficial
reading, and they will not
provide additional information
that would be considered
naturally cooperative.
They're wary that this might
trigger a misrecognition error,
and that's understandable.
Our design should
accommodate for these cases
as well, for these
users as well.
[AUDIO PLAYBACK]
- OK, I found one.
Your driver John should
arrive within six minutes
in a black Toyota Prius.
In the meantime, do you have
the address for your destination
handy?
- Yes.
- Great.
What is it?
- 1950 Charleston
Road Mountain View.
[END PLAYBACK]
JAMES GIANGOLA:
Notice I didn't serve
an error prompt at that point.
I could've, but I didn't.
Like when a little kid
falls in summer camp, right?
You just pick the kid up, brush
him off, say shiny over there,
right?
Don't make a big deal out of it.
Just move along smartly.
So here, user A is more
cautious with speech technology
or simply prefers a
step by step approach
as a matter of preference.
Maybe it's something to
do with their personality.
Then there's user B, who
moves the conversation forward
with the address right away,
as you can see on the right.
They just give the address.
Compare my easy breezy
conversational proposal
on that last slide with a
popular alternative approach.
Let's call this the
neater flowchart approach.
[AUDIO PLAYBACK]
- In the meantime, feel free
to tell me your destination
address.
If you don't have it handy,
you can simply tell the driver
when they arrive.
Go ahead and save
the address now.
[END PLAYBACK]
JAMES GIANGOLA: There's too
much going on in one step
for everyday users.
There's too much going on.
Presumably, this design is to
satisfy the programming metrics
of economy and efficiency.
The design is neat.
It's just a single
dialogue state,
a single turn with a
single piece of information
to collect.
But what if I don't
have the address?
I have to wait through a
timeout to hear the next prompt.
First, we can't possibly know
what a user's timing out means.
They could be timing out
for any number of reasons.
We can't ascribe an [? NLP ?]
interpretation to a time out.
We don't know what it means.
Also, make making
people wait in silence
is disrespectful of their time.
It's abusive.
That's why I hate using
VUIs for customer service,
because I don't like
to time out, like wait
through these timeouts.
My time is really valuable.
So this is a design strategy of
having people time out in order
to signal some
meaningful response is
antithetical to
what conversation
and cooperation are all about.
The bottom line is that
this type of design
is alien to the true and natural
way to manage information flow
and turn taking.
And this is the product
of hundreds of thousands
of years of evolution.
This design just doesn't cut it.
If you thinking that this
slide is a cheap trick,
a straw man, think again.
Design solutions
paralleling this one,
frequently arise when economical
and efficient appearing
flowcharts are
developed and deployed
as VUIs with little regard to
conversational expectations.
So start designing
your conversational app
with best pass sample dialogues
and then flowchart that.
The goal is to create a
superior conversational user
experience, not a flowchart
that's meant to impress.
Users don't care what
your flowchart looks like.
Give people their turn.
That's conversational.
So making users wait
through a timeout
is one of my pet peeves
as a VUI designer.
The next few slides feature
yet another annoying feature
of lots of VUIs, another pet
peeve, another bete noire,
another bugaboo.
I'm talking about applications
that teach users what to say,
as if the VUI were a
touch tone application,
like for technical support.
Press one for billing.
Press two to talk
about your plan.
Press three.
You know those applications.
So let's look at two
ways to prompt users.
Here's way one.
[AUDIO PLAYBACK]
- For more options,
say tell me more.
For more options,
say more options.
For more options, say continue.
[END PLAYBACK]
JAMES GIANGOLA: And
here's way number two.
[AUDIO PLAYBACK]
- Want to hear a
few more choices?
Do you want to hear
some more choices?
[END PLAYBACK]
JAMES GIANGOLA: Now, here
are those same two approaches
applied to a messaging app.
Let's see which one you prefer.
Here is your first new message
from Amber Gomez, received
today at 5:53 PM.
[AUDIO PLAYBACK]
- Hi.
I'm here.
You're not.
Where are you?
- To hear the message
again, say, Repeat.
To reply to it, say, Reply.
And to move on to the
next one, say, Next.
[END PLAYBACK]
JAMES GIANGOLA: OK, thanks
for bearing with that.
Here's way number two, applied
to the same messaging app.
[AUDIO PLAYBACK]
- Here's your first message.
It's from Amber Gomez,
receive it 5:33 PM.
- Hi.
I'm here.
You're not.
Where are you?
- Play it again, Reply,
or Go onto the next one.
[END PLAYBACK]
JAMES GIANGOLA: I think it's
safe to assume we all prefer
VUI number two, right? : The
implicature in VUI number one
is that I don't know how to
use English to get to the next
message or to get
someone to repeat.
Why do I say that?
The persona wouldn't be giving
me the instructions otherwise.
It's like, last night I
saw Chris at a restaurant
with a woman or tomato ketchup.
The person's telling
me that, because they
think it's informative to me.
So assuming cooperation,
to repeat the message,
say repeat, is supposed
to be informative.
The subtext is
proceed with caution.
This interface is not intuitive.
Your existing mental
model of how English works
will get you into trouble here.
Follow my instructions, or else.
Basically, the user experience
is a linguistic straitjacket.
So avoid teaching
commands in a VUI.
If you have to explain a
command, something's wrong.
Go back to the drawing board.
This ain't touch tone.
The whole point of
offering the public a VUI
is that speech is intuitive.
Speech doesn't need to be
taught, a la press three
to do that, or press
the star key to do that.
This is cognitive load
that's inherent to touch tone
applications, because no
one was born knowing what
pressing one or two would do.
But in the VUI
universe, that inherit
burden is now superfluous.
It's unjustified.
Changing gears a bit.
We've seen in the previous
examples that saying too much
is a violation of the
Maxim of Quantity.
Too much information
implies irrelevance.
And VUIs are despised
around the world,
because their designers
seem to have forgotten
that VUI users are not reading.
They're listening,
and there's no way
to fast forward in a VUI.
Think about your own
experiences in customer service
applications-- calling
the bank, the airline,
your cell phone provider.
There's no way to
fast forward in a VUI.
There's no way to skip ahead of
irrelevant messages, irrelevant
options, irrelevant
menus, intrusive up-sells,
legal disclaimers.
We VUI users are at the
mercy of the auditory signal.
We're held captive to the
linearity of the speech signal.
So many VUI designers
have forgotten
that VUI use is inextricably
linked to the passage of time.
But irrelevance,
which is practically
a defining characteristic
of VUI use,
is not inherent
to the technology.
It's just bad design.
Now, we're at the forefront
of an exciting new wave
of VUI design--
smart phones, personal
assistants, talking robots.
And we use these
devices voluntarily.
We pay lots of money for them.
Now, compare this with the
first wave of VUI design,
which was all about
customer service.
Customer service
isn't voluntary,
so we consumers have been a
captive audience, so to speak.
We've been at their mercy.
So I want to now look back
into the history of VUI design,
and I want to look at what's
been so frustrating about VUI
use, particularly with
[INAUDIBLE] relevance.
I want to look at what's been
so frustrating about VUI use
historically, and let's try
to analyze our frustration
in terms of the
cooperative principle.
And hopefully, we won't
repeat those mistakes,
because nowadays,
we cannot afford to.
The audience is no longer
captive in the new wave
of VUI design.
From a technical
perspective, what exactly
is uncooperative about, please
listen carefully, as our menu
options have recently changed?
It's a message you hear all
the time in customer service.
It's irrelevant to pretty much
everyone who listens to it.
And of course, it
would be absurd to try
to fix it with the truth.
The message would read
something like this.
Please listen carefully one,
if you've called before,
two, if the menu options
have changed since then,
and three, if you
happen to remember
what those options were.
The translation is,
please listen carefully,
because this interface
is not at all intuitive.
Am I wrong?
By the way, it's not
conversational to introduce
a reason with the
conjunction as.
That's for literature.
This feels like a letter
written by a bureaucrat.
This is not a likeable person.
In contrast, a good
conversational participant
keeps track of the conversation.
I'm going to repeat that.
A good conversational
participant
keeps track of the conversation.
They have an operational memory
of previous contributions,
and therefore, a
contextual awareness
of their interlocutor.
And this is what's wrong
with, please listen carefully
as our menu options
have recently changed.
It's brashly in your face,
unaware of your context.
And this message
never bodes well
for the quality of what follows.
Here's more irrelevance
and another staple
of the VUI kitsch genre.
Please say or enter your
10 digit telephone number,
one digit at a time,
starting with the area code,
followed by the pound sign.
Punishment.
If I worked for those
companies, here's
how I would design
that experience.
[AUDIO PLAYBACK]
- What's your phone number?
- 430-0988.
- And the area code?
- 917.
[END PLAYBACK]
JAMES GIANGOLA: Right?
Now [? Deni's ?] talk yesterday.
In conversation, there
are no errors, right?
I could have played a error
prompt here, but no, no.
Look.
Shiny over there.
Just wipe yourself off.
You're fine.
You'll be OK.
Easy breezy bike ride
through the park.
Likewise, on the next
slide, not everyone
has to be inconvenienced
with having
to listen to this largely
irrelevant message.
[AUDIO PLAYBACK]
- Stop my service.
- On what date would you
like to stop your service?
This can be any weekday in the
future, other than holidays.
For example, June 25.
Please tell me the date now.
[END PLAYBACK]
JAMES GIANGOLA: I was offended.
This is a real prompt
from a real system.
I played it in text to
speech right now for you,
but when I heard this prompt,
I was actually offended.
Why was I offended?
Because it sounds
like the persona
is accusing me of trying
to steal from the utilities
company.
She's implying that
I might be trying
to stop my service in the past.
Who would do such a thing?
Not me.
Yes, it sounds
like she thinks I'm
trying to pull a fast
one on the power company
by trying to stop my
service in the past.
That sounds like stealing.
I resent that.
Here's what my proposed redesign
for that application would be.
[AUDIO PLAYBACK]
- Stop my service.
- Starting what date?
- Today.
- Actually, the soonest I
can stop service is tomorrow.
Is that OK?
- Yes, that's fine.
[END PLAYBACK]
JAMES GIANGOLA:
So I'm respecting
the user's time, keeping my
messages short and contextually
relevant.
I avoid the off
putting implication
that my user's trying to
stop service in the past.
In other words, they're
trying to steal.
And this is an easy breezy
lightweight interaction.
It's very conversational,
and my strategy here
keeps the dialogue on track.
Here's another example
from a utilities company,
more irrelevance.
[AUDIO PLAYBACK]
- You have reached
the interactive outage
reporting system.
To report an outage,
please speak your responses
when prompted.
At any time, you can say
help to get assistance
in completing the current task.
If you are calling in regard to
a natural gas issue, say gas.
Otherwise, say electric.
[END PLAYBACK]
JAMES GIANGOLA: The
verbosity of this prompt
is presumably to help users
from getting into trouble
with the recognizer, but
none of this preoccupation
is necessary, at least not yet.
And it sounds like we're
in for a rough ride.
Anything irrelevant
here for users
who are not having
problems with this app?
Well, pretty much everything.
Here's my redesign.
[AUDIO PLAYBACK]
- Hello.
This is Sundance County's
automated service
for recording power outages.
To get started, are you
calling about gas or electric?
[END PLAYBACK]
JAMES GIANGOLA: I used to
hear this voicemail recording,
pretty much every day, at a
company I used to work for.
The message was, the
following three new messages
have not been heard.
I used to choke on that
have not been heard part.
If a message is
new, doesn't that
mean that I haven't
heard it yet.
It's a little bit like hearing
this zebra has stripes.
Don't all zebras have stripes?
For me, a new message,
by definition,
is a message I haven't
heard in the same way
that zebras have stripes.
But in this system,
a new message
is one, a message that
has not been heard yet,
or two, a message that has been
heard but not to completion,
or three, it has been
heard to completion,
but you haven't archived it yet.
Seems like a bit much for
everyday people to grok.
I bet they have other
things on their minds.
My colleague Margaret Urban
coined the term tech-splaining.
It means giving overly
technical information
that's lost on
everyday users like,
the following three messages
have not been heard.
So here's a message
from a pretty popular
voice-only assistant.
She says, I'm sorry.
I didn't understand
the question I heard.
For an every day user,
it would be enough
for her to simply say that
she didn't understand.
She could even say she didn't
understand the question.
Why does she say that she
didn't understand the question
she heard.
She can't read.
It's only voice.
Well, the message
can be paraphrased,
you asked a question.
I might have misrecognized
what you asked.
Be that as it may, I tried to
make sense out of what I heard,
which might not have been
what you actually said.
But I couldn't figure out what
that meant either, so sorry.
For everyday users, this
technical nuance thinking,
the distinction between
automatic speech recognition
and natural language processing.
This nuance thinking that
underlines the message is lost.
And the persona just ends
up sounding a little bit
weird and otherworldly.
So in these last
few examples, we've
seen how an excess
of quantities can
lead to some obscure
expressions, which brings us
to Grice's Maxim of Manner,
which is in a conversation,
speakers avoid
obscurity of expression,
and they avoid ambiguity.
So speaking of
obscuring ambiguity,
I want to look at two UIs
whose technical use of language
doesn't seem
linguistically cooperative.
I'm talking about how
technologists understand
the prepositions near and in.
On TripAdvisor, we see that
near is used as a synonym of in.
But I'm a conference goer.
I'm looking for hotels
in Washington D.C.,
not near Washington D.C. I don't
want to stay near Washington.
I want to stay in Washington.
For everyday folks, these
words are not interchangeable,
but this novel use of near seems
to reflect the technologist's
concern for a geographical
radius, a range of distance.
This unfamiliar,
unclear use of language
causes cognitive friction.
Now, hold that thought.
If I'm in Mountain
View, California,
and I ask the Google
Assistant for movies nearby,
she tells me, here's some
movies near Mountain View.
Well, near me and
near Mountain View
are two different things,
because I'm in Mountain View.
So she tells me, here are some
movies near Mountain View,
but the movies she shows
me are in Mountain View.
So there's a couple of
levels of mismatch here.
This might make
sense to an engineer,
but to an everyday user,
it feels like a bug.
So this is something
I'd like to see changed.
And the solution is to just
change near to around--
movies around Mountain View.
Around Mountain View
is pretty loose.
We understand it
means in the vicinity
of in rough, informal
conversational terms.
So instead of redefining
words for users,
what about leveraging
conversational language?
Conversational language
is itself a metaphor.
And what is a metaphor?
It's something
familiar that helps
us understand the unfamiliar.
Familiar language is itself
a gesture of cooperation.
I'm going to give you
some quick examples,
and then I'm going to wrap up.
[AUDIO PLAYBACK]
- The email for this
contact is invalid.
[END PLAYBACK]
JAMES GIANGOLA: OK, leveraging
the conversational metaphor
of an assistant.
[AUDIO PLAYBACK]
- Actually, there's a problem
with the way their email is
listed in your address book.
You might want to
fix it later on.
[END PLAYBACK]
JAMES GIANGOLA:
OK, here's another
before and after example.
[AUDIO PLAYBACK]
- The pause limit
has been reached.
[END PLAYBACK]
JAMES GIANGOLA: The rewrite.
[AUDIO PLAYBACK]
- It looks like you
need some more time.
[END PLAYBACK]
JAMES GIANGOLA: A
few more examples.
[AUDIO PLAYBACK]
- Your payee list currently
contains the following payees.
[END PLAYBACK]
JAMES GIANGOLA: Oh come on.
Does your shopping list
contain peanut butter?
I don't think so.
[AUDIO PLAYBACK]
- Sure.
Here's how you can pay.
[END PLAYBACK]
JAMES GIANGOLA: OK
last before and after.
[AUDIO PLAYBACK]
- The transaction you have
requested is now complete.
[END PLAYBACK]
JAMES GIANGOLA: My
conversational rewrite.
[AUDIO PLAYBACK]
- Done.
[END PLAYBACK]
JAMES GIANGOLA: Or.
[AUDIO PLAYBACK]
- And that went through.
[END PLAYBACK]
JAMES GIANGOLA: Or.
[AUDIO PLAYBACK]
- OK you're all set.
[END PLAYBACK]
JAMES GIANGOLA: So to sum
up, the cooperative principle
is at the gut of conversation.
It perverts-- perverts--
sorry about that.
Easy for me to say.
It pervades every
turn-- and I did
that every time I rehearsed it.
I made that same mistake.
It pervades every
turn in a dialog.
It's not an optional feature.
There's no override.
So imagine two types
of talking primate.
One group communicates with
the cooperative principle,
and the other one doesn't.
Which group do you think has
the evolutionary advantage?
Also, ask yourselves
why is legal language so
hard to understand, so
dense and so frustrating?
Because the language of the law
leaves nothing to inference.
The language of the
law assumes that you're
going to act out
of self-interest
and take advantage of
any potential loopholes.
So it's a [? spans ?] assumption
of the cooperative principle.
The difficulties that you and
I have with legal language
are evidence of the
practical necessity
for the evolution of the
cooperative principle
in human cognition.
And this, in my
opinion, has been
critical to the development
of human civilization.
So the main takeaways
from this presentation
is that people are
naturally cooperative.
We expect cooperation
too, and this principle
prevails over literal
interpretations
and the rules of logic.
I've shown you the
perils of irrelevance
in conversation design.
It disrespects user's time.
It challenges their patience,
and it reinforces frustrations
with VUIs in general.
But good VUI design optimizes
for immediate relevance.
So sharpen the user's focus
and direct their attention
by reducing auditory clutter.
Respect the limits
of short term memory.
The advantage of offering a
VUI is that everyone already
knows how to speak, so leverage
the inherent intuitiveness
of VUI.
You don't need to teach
touch-tone style commands.
Three, recognition
grammar should
be constructed, as
much as possible,
to anticipate
verbal cooperation.
And let's please be more humble
about what the industry calls
recognition errors.
This adjustment in
attitude is sure to have
an effect on the
tone of the messages
we write in response
to so-called misrecs.
Four, personalization means more
than saying welcome back, Pat.
Truly satisfying
personalization should
begin with at least being
informative and relevant
from the user's point of view.
So we haven't had much time
today for a topic this big.
Once we start delving
into the complexities
of conversational design, you'll
see how vast this field really
is.
But if you found
this talk worthwhile,
we've got some great
white papers online
at g.co/dev/ActionsDesign,
written by myself and other
people on our design team.
There's quick reference guides.
There's checklists.
There's videos for
however much time
you have-- one minute,
three minutes, an hour.
A lot of great resources
there on that site.
I believe we are out of time.
Getting the signal from Monica,
saying yes, we're out of time.
Thank you, Monica.
I'll be in the sandbox outside
if you guys want to talk.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]